.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Schach - man nennt es
auch "das Spiel der Könige".
Es geht um das Kompetitive.
Dass man mehr sehen und weiter
rechnen können muss als der Gegner.
Nico Georgiadis
trägt den Titel Schachgrossmeister.
Als einer der Besten der Schweiz
stellt er sich in Indien
am grössten und bedeutendsten
Schachturnier der Welt
seinen Kontrahenten.
- Springer ist auf E7 nicht auf F5.
Er blockiert mich auf G8.
Hört das irgendwann auf im Kopf?
- Nicht direkt nach der Partie.
Ein Sport, mental so fordernd -
Nico ist fast daran zerbrochen.
Es machte mich so kaputt,
dass ich sagte: "Fertig."
Wieso Schach
ihn trotzdem immer wieder mitreisst
und was das Spiel mit ihm macht,
davon handelt dieser Film.
In wenigen Tagen
geht das Abenteuer los.
Für Nico nichts Ungewöhnliches.
Von klein auf
reist der heute 26-Jährige
für seine Lieblingsbeschäftigung -
das Schachspielen - um die Welt.
Diesmal
geht es mit der Nationalmannschaft
nach Chennai im Südosten von Indien.
Ich freue mich mega auf Indien,
ich war noch nie dort.
Ich bin gespannt auf die Kultur.
Aber ich freue mich
auch aufs Schachspielen.
Ich spiele wegen des Jobs
nicht mehr so viel Schach.
Für die Nationalmannschaft
spiele ich am liebsten.
Da gebe ich mehr als sonst
und freue mich im Vorfeld
viel mehr auf das Turnier.
Nico kenne ich schon -
von der Arbeit beim SRF.
Er ist für die Sendung
"Gesichter & Geschichten"
als Videojournalist tätig.
Nico ist gewissenhaft,
aber im Büro fällt er v.a. auf,
weil er laut und chaotisch ist.
Auf seine "andere Welt"
bin ich deshalb umso gespannter.
Diese?
Schach, dieses strukturierte Spiel,
passt nämlich so gar nicht zu ihm.
Nein, die ist es auch nicht.
Habe ich die im Keller unten,
ich Trottel?
Ich war gerade im Keller
und muss nochmals runter.
Er sucht gerade seine Hose.
Oder hier drin.
Wie kann man so ein Chaot sein?
Echt.
Die meisten Schachspieler
sind in ihrer eigenen Welt,
wenn es nicht um Schach geht.
Wobei beim Schach ja auch.
Abgesehen vom Schach
ist man gedankenverloren ...
... und dann
wie weniger konzentriert.
Ein megakomischer Gegensatz.
Schachspieler und Genie -
das könnt ihr streichen.
Ja, sie sind wirklich drin.
Nicos Werdegang zum SRF
finde ich speziell.
2015 hat die Sendung "G&G"
ein Porträt
über ihn als Schachprofi gemacht.
Die Arbeit des Journalisten
hat ihn dermassen beeindruckt,
dass er auch zum Fernsehen wollte.
Er
studierte Publizistikwissenschaften
und bewarb sich
für ein Praktikum beim SRF.
Diese Zielstrebigkeit
hat er wohl von seinem Vater.
Er war es auch,
der Nico zur Schachkarriere pushte.
Dass dein Vater mitkommt,
ist keine Option?
Nein.
Schon lange nicht mehr.
Ich verbiete es ihm.
Wieso?
Es ist sowieso verboten,
dass die Eltern mitkommen.
Und ich will ihn nicht dabeihaben,
weil er mich ...
... mehr stört.
Wir haben Diskrepanzen,
wenn es nicht so gut läuft.
Dann zieht es mich mehr runter,
als es mir helfen würde.
So.
Easy.
Zu seinen Eltern pflegt er
ansonsten ein enges Verhältnis.
Deshalb will er
sich noch von ihnen verabschieden.
Hier in Schindellegi
im Kanton Schwyz
hat er bis vor vier Jahren
mit den Eltern
und seinen beiden jüngeren Schwestern
zusammengelebt.
Hoi.
- Hoi.
Hey. Hoi.
Hoi.
Hoi. Tschau.
- Hoi.
Wow.
Ja, schön sieht es aus. Hei, ei, ei.
Hast du das Visum
aus der Tasche ausgepackt?
Ja, das Visum ist ready,
der Laptop und der Pass auch.
Super.
Ein megaschöner Brunch, wirklich.
- Ja ...
Nicos Vater
ist zielstrebig und ehrgeizig.
Er hat seinem Sohn
das königliche Spiel beigebracht.
Schon früh
erkannte er Nicos Potenzial.
Man denkt immer,
man müsse mathematisch begabt sein.
Das war Nico nicht.
Er war Durchschnitt, mathematisch.
Er durchlief die Schulen
zwar sehr einfach,
aber Nicos Manko ist,
dass er nicht so fleissig ist.
Es geht um die Stärken.
- Genau.
Seine grosse Stärke
ist sicher aussergewöhnlich.
Das habe ich gemerkt,
als er drei oder vier war.
Wir spielten Memory und er
hatte alle Karten und ich keine.
Das Bildgedächtnis ist etwas,
das ihm aussergewöhnliche Chancen
im Schachsport gegeben hat.
Im Schach muss man
viele Züge vorausdenken können
und es braucht gute Intuition.
Genauso hat der Vater
auch Nicos Karriere geplant:
Als der Kleine sechs Jahre alt war,
meldete er ihn im Schachclub an,
büffelte mit ihm Schachbücher,
schickte ihn sogar
für mehrere Monate nach Spanien
zur dortigen Nummer 1.
Hat Nico euch manchmal leidgetan?
Extrem.
V.a., wenn etwas nicht gut lief -
da wurde Papi so wütend.
Da stand man daneben
und schüttelte einfach den Kopf.
Es kann immer mal schlecht laufen.
Da ist schon ein grosser Druck,
der aufgebaut wird, oder?
Meinen Sie, von uns aus?
Auch vom Vater, der da mit ...
- Ja, ein gewisser Druck ist da.
Stimmt.
Er will selbst auch gewinnen
und weiterkommen.
Den Druck macht er sich
wahrscheinlich am meisten.
Ich hoffe, ich habe ihm
den Druck eher etwas genommen.
Und er drückte
dann halt noch etwas mehr.
Diese harten Worte
scheinen ihn nicht zu beeindrucken.
Man muss verstehen: Wenn man
im Sport weit kommen möchte,
geht ohne die Unterstützung
der Eltern meistens nichts.
Nur so hat es Nico
zum Grossmeister geschafft.
Dieser international anerkannte Titel
ist ein Ritterschlag
in der Schachwelt.
Bisher haben ihn in der Schweiz
nur fünf Personen erhalten.
Nico war damals 21 Jahre alt.
Danach fiel Nico in ein Loch.
Nico war mal an einem Punkt,
erzählte er mir,
an dem er wirklich aufhören wollte.
Das war genau der Punkt.
- Okay.
Wie war das, als Sie erfuhren, dass
Ihr Sohn vielleicht aufhören will?
Das habe ich
gar nie richtig mitgekriegt.
Wenn ich es dir gesagt hätte -
ich weiss nicht.
Das war ... äh ...
Das war ein Kampf mit mir selbst.
Ich kommunizierte das nicht gross.
Ich dachte: "Ich arbeite mit einer
Mentaltrainerin oder höre auf."
Weil es dich fertiggemacht hat.
- Genau.
Da die Mentaltrainer-Option
gut aussah, wollte ich das machen.
Ich habe das nicht mit ihm geteilt.
Du hättest keine Freude gehabt,
wenn ich das gesagt hätte.
Es wäre schade gewesen
um all die Jahre der Ausbildung.
Und auch
für den Schweizer Schachsport.
Das interessiert mich in dem Moment
nicht. Es geht ja nur um mich.
Logo.
Dass Nico seinem Vater
nichts davon erzählte, erstaunt mich.
Bei der Arbeit scheut er nämlich
keine Konfrontation.
Nico ist wie immer knapp dran.
* Lachen *
Hi.
- How are you?
Die Schweiz schickt ein Frauen-
und ein Männerteam nach Indien.
Pro Team sind es fünf Spielerinnen
oder fünf Spieler, so die Statuten.
Mit dabei
auch ein Captain und ein Trainer.
Wie geht es?
- Gut, und du?
Gut, gut, etwas nervös.
Die beiden Teams
reisen extra einen Tag früher an,
um sich
an Klima und Kultur zu gewöhnen.
Indien ist erstmals Austragungsort
der Schacholympiade.
Ursprünglich
wäre Russland Gastgeberland gewesen,
doch dann kam
der Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine.
Für Indien eine grosse Ehre,
zumal sich das Land
als Wiege des Schachs sieht.
Rund 2'000 Spielerinnen und Spieler
aus 186 Nationen
nehmen am grössten und wichtigsten
Schachturnier der Welt teil.
Krass. Jeder hat einen Schnauz.
- Wirklich jeder.
Vielleicht ist das
wie der Dresscode im Militär.
Nein, auch Private. Schau.
- Ah, wirklich?
Ja. Sonst hätte ich es gesagt.
In Chennai
leben rund 5 Mio. Menschen.
Es ist laut und hektisch.
Nico hat das zuvor noch nie erlebt.
Die Mädchen sind süss.
Schau, da sind sie wieder.
Geil.
Schau dir das an.
Eingepfercht wie Fische im Aquarium.
Es ist wirklich krass,
was für eine andere Welt das ist.
Man weiss das, bevor man kommt.
Das sagen alle.
Sebi war schon mal in Indien.
Aber wenn man die Strasse sieht:
Da laufen plötzliche Kühe rum
und es hat so viele Menschen ...
Das komplette Chaos
und doch funktioniert es.
Habe ich noch nie gesehen so.
Sehr beeindruckend.
Schau mal die Baustelle.
Nicos Hotel
ist vom ganzen Trubel abgeschottet.
Das Turnier beginnt mit
der traditionellen Eröffnungsfeier.
Die Stadt hat sich
für das prestigeträchtige Turnier
herausgeputzt.
Chennai gilt schliesslich
als das Mekka des Schachs in Indien.
Auf jeder Schachwerbung
sind Premierminister Narendra Modi
und M.K. Stalin, der Regierungschef
dieses Bundesstaates im Süden,
zu sehen.
Beide werden
an den Feierlichkeiten erwartet.
Nico wäre lieber im Hotel geblieben,
um sich auszuruhen.
Komisch.
Ich erlebe ihn immer
als sehr unternehmenslustig.
Noch nie so viele Militärmenschen
an einem Ort gesehen.
Für dieses Turnier
stehen laut Regierung
22'000 Sicherheitsleute im Einsatz.
* Unverständliche Durchsage *
* Indische Musik *
Switzerland.
* Jubel *
Syria.
Hat es noch Platz für uns?
Es war so heiss,
das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
Wir mussten
in einem Kämmerchen warten.
Es war etwa 50 °C.
So dicht gedrängt
wie in der Sardinenbüchse.
Dann hiess es,
wir müssten 2 Std. warten.
Wir so: "Was?"
Ich dachte, ich sterbe.
Die pompöse und sich
irgendwann wiederholende Show
zieht sich in die Länge.
Krass.
Der Grund:
Der Premierminister von Indien -
Narendra Modi - hat sich verspätet.
Good evening, Chennai.
* Jubel *
Sport is beautiful because
it has the inherent power to unite.
Sie haben es gut gemacht,
aber jetzt kommt der Teil,
wo nur noch Reden kommen.
Da spüren sie sich nicht mehr ganz.
Bei 20-minütigen Reden
kann man nicht mehr zuhören.
Ja ...
Nach 3-4 Std. hat man es
langsam gesehen und will gehen.
Die Schacholympiade
ist offiziell eröffnet.
* Pompöse Musik *
Endlich.
Es war endlos,
aber wir haben es geschafft.
Vielleicht bereue ich,
dass ich gekommen bin.
Der Anfang war cool,
mit den Fahnen, aber dann ...
Come on, move a bit closer.
Come on. Come here.
- No, no, no, no, no.
Why not? Like this. Okay.
Because then I'm like her.
- No, it's fine.
Geduld
ist auch im Job nicht Nicos Stärke.
Dafür darf er sich
für einmal als Star fühlen.
Hm? Ah, shake hands.
Die erste von insgesamt
elf Schachrunden steht an.
Nico beginnt den Tag
so wie immer vor einer Partie:
mit einem speziellen Ritual.
* Epische Musik *
Dass Nico sehr sportlich ist,
weiss ich.
Wir spielen ab und zu
gegeneinander Tennis.
Er macht daraus
immer einen Wettkampf
und regt sich
über jedes verlorene Game auf.
Aber Turnübungen?
Heute brauchte ich das richtig.
Wie sind deine Shakes?
- Richtig geil.
Wirklich?
Wenn mein Ritual durch ist,
bin ich fit,
egal, was vorher passiert ist.
Darum mache ich das: Um vor jeder
Partie gleich fit zu sein.
Um immer ein gutes Gefühl zu haben.
Ready?
Die tägliche Busfahrt
wird zum neuen Ritual.
Sich frei bewegen ist für alle
Schachspieler strikt verboten.
Die Regierung
hat ein strenges Sicherheitskonzept.
Gespielt wird
in zwei unterschiedlichen Hallen.
Jeweils vier pro Mannschaft.
Einer setzt aus.
Nicos Vater verfolgt die Partie
online von zu Hause aus.
In der ersten Runde spielen
die Männer gegen Mauretanien.
Punktemässig ein schwächerer Gegner.
Die Schweiz hingegen bewegt sich im
vorderen Fünftel aller Mannschaften.
Das will aber nichts heissen.
Ein falscher Zug
und die Partie kann vorbei sein.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Im Saal herrscht
striktes Rede- und Handyverbot.
Erlaubt sind hingegen das Herumgehen
und der Gang zur Toilette.
Denn so eine Partie
dauert meist über 4 Std.
Gewonnen.
Alles andere als ein Sieg
wäre eine Katastrophe gewesen,
wenn der Gegner
nominell so viel schwächer ist.
Trotzdem ist wichtig,
gut ins Turnier zu starten,
gut zu spielen
und souverän zu gewinnen.
So still wie während des Spiels
erlebe ich Nico nie im Büro.
Es geht um das Kompetitive.
Dass man mehr sehen und weiter
rechnen können muss als der Gegner.
Ja. Das macht es einfach aus.
Deshalb mag ich es trotzdem.
Auch wenn es megaruhig ist.
Hi.
Ein neuer Tag bricht an.
Nach einem zweiten Sieg
steht nun in der dritten Runde
einer der stärksten Gegner an:
Indien.
Was geht dir durch den Kopf?
Nichts. Einfach nichts.
Den Fokus zu behalten, den ich habe.
Was heisst das?
Ich bin konzentriert
und warte nur darauf, ans Brett
zu sitzen und den Zug zu machen.
Jetzt
muss die Zeit überbrückt werden.
Und da versuche ich an
nichts zu denken.
Der grossgewachsene Nico
ist ein beliebtes Fotosujet.
With the thumb.
- Cheers.
Mit Daumen.
- Yes. Mit Daumen. Höher.
Cheers, thank you.
Sein Gegner:
der 16-jährige Dommaraju Gukesh.
Schon mit zwölf Jahren Grossmeister.
In dem Alter hatte Nico
nicht nur Schach im Kopf.
Es war immer ein Kampf.
Ich wollte viel Freizeit,
aber auch viel Schach spielen.
Es war ein Abwägen.
Mein Vater wollte,
dass ich mehr spiele.
Ich eher weniger.
Wir fanden einen Weg
und ich arbeitete damals
verbissen am Ziel Grossmeister.
Ich wusste,
dass ich dafür spielen muss.
Der Kompromiss:
zweimal Training pro Woche
und am Wochenende von Schachturnier
zu Schachturnier reisen.
Bereust du es manchmal,
nicht mehr investiert zu haben?
Nein, ich bin zufrieden damit,
wo ich bin.
Sein Niveau
hätte ich wohl eh nie erreicht,
selbst mit viel trainieren.
Nico gibt so schnell aber nicht auf.
In Sachen Ehrgeiz
steht er seinem Vater in nichts nach.
Please start you clocks.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Die ersten paar Schachzüge ist Nico
am Vormittag schon durchgegangen.
Am Tisch nebendran: Magnus Carlsen,
der amtierende Schachweltmeister
aus Norwegen.
Wer hat die besseren Nerven,
die bessere Intuition?
Wer denkt schneller?
Konzentriert sind jedenfalls beide.
Nicht einmal,
dass ich sie filme, stört sie.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Doch gegen Gukesh
ist Nico chancenlos.
Wie stark zieht dich
eine solche Niederlage runter?
Schon ziemlich.
Das ist erst der Anfang.
Es zieht mich
den ganzen Abend runter.
Aber ja, das gehört dazu.
Was denkstdu,
was dein Vater zur Partie sagt?
Dass ich scheisse gespielt habe.
Stresst das noch mehr?
- Nein, es ist mir scheissegal.
Ich weiss selbst,
dass ich scheisse gespielt habe.
Der Vater
wird es ihm noch persönlich sagen.
Sie stehen in regem SMS-Kontakt.
Die Teamkollegen wissen,
wie hart Nico eine Niederlage trifft.
Am besten lässt man ihn mal
in Ruhe, dann kommt es schon wieder.
Am Abend ist er wieder gut drauf.
Das Gute ist,
dass wir beide verloren haben.
Dann können wir easy
miteinander reden.
Hätte er gewonnen und ich verloren,
wäre es schwieriger.
Das stimmt.
Wenn er sich schon im Tennis wegen
eines verlorenen Games so aufregt,
wie muss es sich
jetzt für ihn anfühlen?
Dass er eine Runde aussetzt,
sagt jedenfalls schon alles.
Stattdessen will er
mit seiner Teamkollegin Camille
zu den Tempelanlagen
ganz in der Nähe.
Weil sie nicht im Turnierbus reisen,
muss ein Polizist mit.
Ist es üblich, dass Polizisten
die Hotelgäste begleiten
oder ist das wegen des Turniers?
- (Fahrer) Nur wegen des Turniers.
(Camille) Ist es sonst gefährlich
oder geht es um Extrasicherheit?
Extrasicherheit.
Sie wollen,
dass niemand zu Schaden kommt.
Dadurch schränken sie uns
aber auch etwas ein.
Du kennst Nico, seit er neun war.
Wie war er damals?
Er war sehr schüchtern.
Er war sehr nett,
aber sehr schüchtern.
Er hat nicht viel gesagt.
Vielleicht weil ich Französisch
sprach und er Deutsch
und sein Englisch war nicht so gut.
Wir haben nur gelächelt und gelacht.
Er war einige Jahre so schüchtern,
dann hat es geändert.
Lustig, ich empfand mich damals
nicht als schüchtern.
Vielleicht war das mit uns.
- Vielleicht mit Mädchen.
Als ich ein Kind war,
hatte ich Angst vor ihnen.
Hast du immer noch.
Sie macht mich neugierig.
Darüber
will ich später mehr erfahren.
Zuerst aber zu den Tempeln.
Der Tempelbezirk von Mamallapuram
gehört zu den wichtigsten
archäologischen Fundorten Südindiens.
Und gehört heute
zum UNESCO-Weltkulturerbe.
Welcome to Mamallapuram.
This is the temple.
On the top
you can see the Dravidian style.
And the pillars
are in the Roman style.
Red, yeah?
- Für ein gutes Spiel.
Du gewinnst.
- Okay.
Sie braucht auch Rot.
- Yeah, yeah.
Red?
- Nein, hier hat es kein Rot.
No, white as well.
Sie gewinnt,
sie gewinnt das Schachspiel.
Für gute Energie.
Keine Probleme.
- Thanks.
Ich bin überrascht:
Es sei Nicos erster Ausflug
an einem Schachturnier.
Ich erlebe ihn eigentlich
als neugierigen
und interessierten Journalisten.
Ich bin so fokussiert aufs Turnier,
dass es mir mehr wert ist,
gut zu spielen,
anstatt etwas zu sehen.
Es ist ein Opfer, das ich mache.
Hier haben wir aber Zeit gefunden,
es zu machen.
Und wenn ich das so sehe ...
Schade,
dass wir das nicht mehr machen.
Du hast gestern
gegen Gukesh gespielt.- Ja.
Wie alt ist er?
- 16.
Er hat gewonnen.
- Er hat mich auseinandergenommen.
Ich mag dein fieses Lachen.
Die zwei
brechen den Ausflug irgendwann ab.
Schach hat Priorität.
This is a doorkeeper.
- Ah, yeah.
Auch die nächsten Tage sind streng.
Die Bilanz der Schweizer Mannschaft:
durchzogen.
Jeden Morgen bleibt der sonst
so gesellige Nico auf seinem Zimmer.
Allein.
Er übt das sog. Eröffnungsspiel.
D.h., er geht die ersten paar Schach-
züge der jeweiligen Partie durch.
Und erhofft sich dadurch
einen Vorteil.
Man ist sehr oft einsam.
Empfindest du das auch so?
Ja.
Als Schachprofi
trainiert man oft allein.
Das ist einsam.
Deshalb
wollte ich nie Schachprofi werden.
Das ist
zu eintönig und einsam für mich.
Als Profi
musst du allein trainieren.
Das liegt mir nicht.
Ich brauche Interaktion.
Daraus hole ich meine Energie.
Nicos Leben verläuft geradlinig.
Was er anpackt, gelingt.
So zumindest nehme ich es wahr.
Doch wo stösst
auch er an seine Grenzen?
Ich bin schon lange Single.
Da fragt man sich irgendwann:
Ja ...
Wieso? Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiss das,
ich suche es auch selbst.
Ich brauche sehr viel Freiheit,
also Zeit für mich selbst.
Aber ich frage mich trotzdem, wieso.
Was kann ich besser machen,
damit ich bei anderen Menschen
besser ankomme?
Die Frage stelle ich mir oft.
Ich glaube,
ich will zu vielen gefallen.
Das ist eine Schwäche von mir.
Dadurch mache ich mir viele Gedanken
über alles, was ich mache.
Gedanken, die jetzt gerade
in den Hintergrund geraten.
Die elfte und letzte Partie steht an.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Wie sehr willst du
genau dieses Spiel gewinnen?
Um jeden Preis.
Das Turnier gut abzuschliessen
ist das Wichtigste.
Sonst hat man danach
ein schlechtes Gefühl.
Die Gegner heute: Israel.
Von der Bewertung her
sind sie ähnlich stark.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Gewonnen.
Sein Vater sass ihm während
dieser 4 Std. auch heute im Nacken,
wenn auch aus der Ferne.
Heute hat er sicher
eine Riesenfreude -
fast wie ich wahrscheinlich.
Oder mehr?
- Nein.
Eine solche Freude,
wie ich gerade habe -
mehr freuen geht nicht.
Ich hatte es angekündigt.
Ich sagte ihm gestern ...
... ich werde gewinnen.
Und er: "Ja, ja, schauen wir mal."
Er war sehr enttäuscht,
als ich verloren habe. Wie ich auch.
Es ist immer so.
Er hat mich aber nicht kritisiert.
Einfach nur mitgelitten.
Du bist wie ein Superstar.
Wie fühlt sich das an?
Heute super. Heute mache ich alles.
Die Schachfans wissen nicht,
wer er ist und wie er heisst.
Aber wen kümmert das?
Thank you.
Eight today. Why did I give that?
I can't sign on G7.
That's a dark square.
- True. Where did you sign?
F7.
- Okay.
Der letzte Abend bricht an.
Die offizielle Siegesfeier
schwänzen sie.
Die Schweiz
hat es nur auf Platz 51 geschafft.
Gold geht an Usbekistan.
Salud.
- Cheers.
Chin up.
- Du musst nie vergessen:
Schach ist trotzdem das,
was du am besten machst.
Ja.
Verglichen mit allem anderen.
- Darum ist Verlieren so schlimm.
Stell dir vor: Du verlierst in dem,
was du am besten kannst im Leben.
Darum ist Verlieren so schlimm -
v.a. im Schach.
Es ist alles verhältnismässig.
- Genau.
Wie viele Leute in der Schweiz
wären gerne an deiner Stelle?
Schachspieler schon.
Sie hatten sich nicht den Sieg
erhofft, aber doch etwas mehr.
Dennoch wird die Reise
in guter Erinnerung bleiben.
Ich habe wieder mal gemerkt,
dass die Schachwelt schon meins ist.
Ich fühle mich megawohl
mit diesen Leuten.
Nicht an jedem Schachturnier,
aber an diesem Turnier
mit dieser Mannschaft
fühlte ich mich wirklich megawohl.
Ich kam gerne hierher
und will es auch nicht missen.
Ich höre doch nicht
so schnell mit Schach auf,
wie ich während Corona
mal gedacht habe.
Da dachte ich, ich könnte aufhören.
Aber jetzt, wo es wieder da ist,
ist es schon sehr schön.
Ich geniesse es.
Nico hat mich nicht nur nach Indien,
sondern auf eine Reise
in seine Welt mitgenommen.
Je länger das Turnier dauerte, desto
mehr hat er mir vor Augen geführt:
Schach
ist nicht nur das Spiel der Könige,
es ist Nicos Spiel.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022